what up space fam golden here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss early
news on one of the biggest one piece
chapters it's even more hyped than the
last one that introduced us to the final
straw hat so make sure to stay tuned for
this one if you do enjoy these early
chapter spoiler videos and want to keep
them coming smash that like button to
set off the wano celebration fireworks
and yes your smash will really set off
fireworks if you didn't know yet if you
haven't make this the video you joined
the knock em up by subscribing and
hitting that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future one-piece videos and updates now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all okay so if you'll
remember last chapter ended with a very
conclusion feel to the wano arc no big
question raised in the end or
cliffhanger just a celebration of
juano's liberation and momo's
inauguration and oh boy does oda ever
make up for not having a cliffhanger
last chapter with this one this chapter
is called a new morning so again has
that new arc new adventure feel to it
which makes sense on the cover the
germans encounter caesar so they're
having fun doing their own thing we're
told zunisha left because the borders
are closed now that seems weird and
sudden as a former member of old joy
boy's crew we would have loved to see
more of him we'd love to see him give us
details of the world but luffy didn't
want to hear it all from rayleigh so i
guess it's not a surprise that zunisha
didn't spoil the beans either i'm
thinking sunisha could have at least
stayed to help protect the island
against the upcoming threat which we'll
get to but i guess not again this is
like a rough summary of the chapter so
we'll know more when the full translated
pages come out but let me know what you
think of zunisha suddenly peacing out
since the borders are still closed and
momo's not opening them yet we then get
hawkins revealing in a talk with drake
that he meant himself when he said a
certain person only had one percent
chance of survival he actually predicted
kaido's defeat how crazy is that but
didn't commit another betrayal because
of his pride and i gotta say i kind of
respect that he's not like apoo where a
pooh will switch sides as many times as
you allow him to cool to catch up with
the supernova here and again i'm
guessing hawkins will survive into the
future so that one percent chance of
survival is kind of a lesson to not just
live based off of probability because if
luffy did that he definitely would not
have gotten as far as he did then seven
days pass no chance anyone can argue
that the fight is not over if kaido
hasn't come back to finish the fight in
seven days so even more so than last
time the identity of luffy as a yonko
killer ayanko destroyer or ayanko
defeater is settling in we get to see
progress made in the land of wano which
is a nice touch i'm looking forward to
seeing the exact specifics for what kind
of progress i appreciate the fact that
it's not just like okay let's save this
place leave and hope they figure it out
we actually get to see some progress
before we go which makes sense
considering how long we've been in wano
now we need some more payoff and to see
how much of a difference luffy's made
apu and inby seem to have made up with
the alliance and i'm not surprised appu
will make up with anybody hawkins's
refusal to switch sides easily stands
out all the more because someone as
fickle as apu is present in this arc i
wonder if oda will redeem apoo's
character by the end of the series but
so far he's definitely not a likable
dude then we got a big serious reveal
even though this is one piece and you
can never be sure that characters will
die some characters have died during the
war specifically ashrae and ezo died izo
died with his exchange against the cp0
agent maha obviously these aren't main
characters but it is sad to see
ashwanizo go i always thought izo was
very cool with his choice of weapons and
also the fact that he was associated
with the whitebeard pirates didn't hurt
either we then jumped to a few comedy
and fan service scenes that include
yamato and the straw hats cannot wait to
see those because this is super vague
here i'm wondering if luffy is fine now
or if he's still recovering same with
zoro and then we get the craziest bit of
news even though it's not necessarily
surprising we're shown that admiral
ryokugu aka green bull is on his way to
wano there was mention of admirals going
to wanna we knew the world government
were preparing to attack if luffy won
and in our one piece podcast we did
mention that they could easily be
accompanied with an admiral so it seems
like that has indeed happened we don't
know if only green bull has shown up or
if he came along with other admirals
like fujitora but nevertheless it is big
news because green bull is in all
likelihood zoro's father but before i
get into that it does say there's no
break next week so props to oda he's
been super consistent with these
chapters even though we are in a super
hype part of the story right now and he
could easily get away with taking more
breaks so we'll find out more about
green bull very soon so make sure you
are subscribed and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss it yo future goes
in here we got some new crazy updates of
this chapter from oro japan so it pretty
much says that we still don't see green
bull's face but he has a flower on his
back that he uses to push himself and
fly so there's speculation could this be
uh plant-based fruit as a lot of us
predicted that explains the you know not
being not having to eat for three years
thing the photosynthesis and all that
but it also raised the question could it
be some kind of mythical zone as well so
let me know what you think about that
crazy news we're also told that one
piece will officially enter a one-month
break hiatus from june 27th to july 25th
so that oda can prepare for the final
saga huge
huge news final saga in and of itself is
like a big drop but yeah it makes sense
as i was saying oda definitely deserves
a break we've been getting some amazing
content finally we got some spoilers
saying that morgan's already published
the news in the newspapers you know what
that means guys we're going to be
getting bounties real soon can't wait
and we see the crew recovered including
zorro which is another question i had so
that's cool and we also see that green
bull is accompanied by a buster call so
wow this is going to be an insane
chapter but back to the green bull
zoro's dad discussion if you don't know
there has been a theory that green bull
is zorro's father for a long time i'm
pretty sure i first heard this theory
discussed in detail from a morge video
called proof green bull is zoro's father
published over eight months ago and he
even said in the video he's not the
first to mention it so it's definitely
not a new theory but with recent events
it just seems more and more obvious and
props to morge we even said in that
video that green bull would come to wano
and he was clearly right we know wano
has been a zoro focused arc in the way
whole cake has been a sanji focused arc
but wow it just keeps going zoro made a
yonko bleed his own blood he blocked the
uncle combo attack he beat king the
yonko commander with the highest known
bounty we got important backstory stuff
since he and his ancestors are clearly
from wano and now it looks like his
father is fast approaching for a meet-up
whether it will be to fight or for
another reason we don't know yet it was
suggested that green bull like fujitora
is not very admiralish in the sense that
they seem to have better moral compasses
than akainu and kizaru and so there is a
very strong possibility that they are
undercover using their position to help
crush the world government or at least
to change it from within we know zoro
has to be related to his lookalike
shimotsuki ushimaru who has a similar
fighting style similar appearance and
the list goes on ushimaru was shown in
the anime wearing a cloak with a bull on
it and the bull was black and green so
there is a clear connection there with
green bull and thus there's a clear
connection with green bull and zoro now
for just the similarities between zorro
and green bull morge actually in his
video made a good point that zorro and
green bull were introduced in similar
ways zoro was fasting when luffy met him
and greenbell is fasting when he's
introduced he even tells fujitora he
hasn't eaten in three years but he might
if a gal fed him and in zorro's case he
did eat the rice balls the girl brought
him near the beginning of the story now
green bull says eating is a pain to him
and he hasn't eaten for three years
which seems super human as if it's a
fruit power thing rather than just a
fast but these parallels shouldn't be
ignored either way foregoing eating has
been associated with one of specific
characters like ushimaru and zorro so
it's another point that lends weight to
greenville being from wano just as his
friend fujitora clearly appears to be
now that green bull is coming and since
we just had a focus on sanji and his
father last arc it seems more likely
than ever that zorro during this arc of
his will now have to confront his own
dad since luffy usopp and sanji already
have famous living dads it's even more
likely that zorro's dad will be someone
important and living like green bull i
also haven't mentioned the obvious yet
that zoro is associated with the color
green more than any other but it's still
a fact that shouldn't be ignored when
looking at green bull and his connection
to zorro the other cool thing is if
zoro's dad is green bull as i believe he
probably is then all four of these
mentioned dads will be powerful people
from different areas of life one being a
revolutionary one a pirate one an
admiral and one a king scientist so yeah
this is big news whether you think
greenville is zorro's dad or not because
he is nonetheless a character shattered
mystery and an admiral to boot so you
can bet he's gonna be interesting to
watch and to learn about regardless of
his relationship to zorro let me know
what you think since the truth will come
out soon place your bets for bragging
rights in the comments is green bull
zoro's father or not and while you're at
it how do you think he could go three
years without eating is it fruit powers
as i think it is or do you think you can
take samurai epicness so far that that's
actually possible once you reach a
certain level at least in the world of
one piece could fasting be seen as green
bulls version of fujitora blinding
himself and will greenville attack and
fight the straw hats or actually allow
them to escape revealing that he's
actually on their side and if this is
zoro's dad just as last arc dealt with
sanji's dad will it be an even further
clue that as i've been expecting luffy's
dad will play a bigger role in the next
arc since now as the worry of liberation
sun god luffy seems to be integral to
dragon's revolutionary mission yes i
have a lot of questions but one thing we
don't need to question one thing we know
for certain and that one thing is you
should smash that like button and set
off the wano fireworks if you enjoyed
this video and want to see more like it
if you haven't make this the video you
joined the nakama by subscribing and
hitting that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future one-piece videos and updates
while you wait for the full translated
pages review to come out feel free to
check out my huge and growing one-piece
playlist that includes videos on all
yonko warlords supernova mythical zones
oh yeah and admirals and much more link
to that is in the description and until
next time see you space cowboys